[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily verdict watch in
the trial of an ohio woman accused of
killing an army veteran
our experts break down the alleged
murderous plot and
unsealed depositions in the case of
millionaire pedophile
jeffrey epstein what his former house
manager is accusing gallane maxwell of
doing
plus a rescue caught on camera how
police saved this woman from her minivan
sinking into a river
and a staten island man gets sworn by
officers
hear from the man accusing nypd of
excessive force
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a noise complaint ended with a fight and
an internal affairs investigation
when witnesses captured what happened on
camera
you can't be doing this you can't
nypd says namir awade the man you see
here in cuffs
is facing charges of disorderly conduct
obstructing governmental administration
and resisting arrest but his attorney
says his paperwork
only lists resisting arrest joining me
now
is namira wade and his attorney eric
subin gentlemen
thanks for joining us today my pleasure
yeah ramirez let's start with you i know
we couldn't see the whole video but it's
chaotic walk us through what happened
that night
so i was uh front of uh family business
on staten island uh the second night of
the election
uh and an unmarked car walked into a
parking lot
which is where my family business is
and they were making weird noises uh 12
30 in the morning and they were playing
with the speaker and the flashlight
through the windows
where you can't see where it was tinted
and it cracked a little bit from the top
uh and um you know i i yelled
out loud i said guys keep it quiet
people are sleeping it's 12 30 in the
morning
and uh they come back at me with a a
weird
noise and uh you know it sounds like it
will make a fun of you know not
respecting my
you know my word and the the way how i
said it and they just kept going
going at it with the flashlight with the
and the speaker
and uh know you know i avoid them
a few minutes later i avoid them i
walked away to the side of uh where i
was staying where i got
uh rested and i was sitting down on the
bench
the unmarked car drive off of the
parking lot and
uh recycle uh mayor you would say in the
middle of the street and come back
and both officers came out and wearing
nybd which is i didn't know they were in
my bb and soon they came out
i did make it clear to them i said oh
i'm sorry i didn't know you guys were
nybd i was just trying to tell you guys
be quiet because people are sleeping
uh one of the officers asked for my id i
asked a couple of times what do you need
my d4 what do you need my d4
it's not that i refuse to give the id i
didn't have it on me because
i was just i live off the block from the
store and
uh he just kept going non-explanation
uh very aggressive another officer kept
rolling in his arms had he had his fist
ready buying his lip
uh you know and uh
i i kept calling for back up for no
reason he soon he came out of the car he
said you're gonna get arrested tonight i
have no clue why
no explanation just you know he bristol
buying he called for backup
cops more cops start coming in the more
cops came in
he started getting louder the other
officer kept getting closer and rolling
up his arms
getting more you know aggressive all my
mind is sitting on the officer on the
left
side hands where he was buying his lip
and he had his fists ready you know
automatically thing you're not thinking
now
they're cops you think of you know three
gangs
you're ready to fight or they're ready
to fight you and you're just worried
about
where you're exactly thinking or what do
you want to do and we can see it there
and
like we can see it there in the video as
you're describing it it seems like a
quiet experience
eric talk to me about this excessive
force complaint you're
you're filing well it's not just going
to be excessive force uh it's going to
be false arrest if they continue with
these trumped up charges
which the only thing listed on a desk
appearance ticket is resisting arrest
with no underlying charge
it's going to be assault and it's going
to be battery in addition to a false
arrest and a malicious prosecution i
mean
if the police are allowed to use some
force to effectuate illegal arrest
but they're not allowed to lay hands on
somebody and commit a battery if they're
not effectuating a legal arrest which
clearly
uh this is not i mean you're showing
some of the video footage here we've got
about uh 10 or so eyewitnesses customers
from this
uh delhi bodega including uh some of the
people who worked there
someone named relatives who are also
working there um and
um we've got surveillance video i mean
this is the mayor's business we've got a
dozen or so surveillance videos from
every angle of this building
you can see everything that happens here
from soup to nuts and merit didn't
commit
any crime violation whatsoever so this
is not a legal or valid arrest in any
way shape or form so
excessive force you know and police
brutality that is going to be one
element of it but it's really an assault
and battery at the end of the day
these police officers got out of uh got
out of their unmarked vehicle
and came and escalated what would
otherwise be a totally innocuous
situation of
a private citizen on his own private
property guarding his business
around the time of the election night uh
concerned about possible tensions rising
and then tensions did rise but it
happened to be with the police with the
police and without any type of legal
justification
yeah now just quickly eric i'm only
eyeballing it before we got to head out
but
how many officers were there or or in
amir can you tell us how many officers
it was like 20 30
what do you guys think it looks like
about 20 and what uh
what the first two officers kept saying
to him over and over again is i'm going
to get the whole precinct down here i'm
going to get the whole precinct down
here
without any uh sort of explanation as to
why and he called in what's essentially
a 1085 but he brought the entire 120
120-second precinct down
for a guy minding his own business on
his own property committing absolutely
no crime which is
uh completely validated by the multitude
of video evidence that we have
uh from the beginning to the end and
then some uh so it's really the entire
thing that's there to really just beat
on this uh
poor individual for really no legal
justification whatsoever
guys eric namire i want to thank you
very much i see you're in a truck there
you're a working man but you still came
out
and had time for us greatly appreciated
best of luck on the case and again thank
you both for joining us
so yeah so about
30 people or something that jumped this
guy because he was quote unquote making
too much noise that makes no
sense terry i'm even seeing a couple
swings to the head
by some of these officers how do you
think that fact will play out in a civil
case
well i think attorney subin put it very
well he stated that
they're not just going to bring
unnecessary use of force they could
also bring assault and battery and
malicious prosecution if in fact the
charges are not dropped
so i think they have a great case i
think the police
should not have used that amount of
force it's only supposed to be necessary
to make the arrest and it didn't seem to
me one that there was
any necessary use and two that there
wasn't even probable cause for an arrest
so
i think they have a very good civil case
i think so
too it's going to be great quite a case
that we're going to follow along here at
the long crime daily
but still ahead jeffrey epstein's former
madam accused of taking
topless photos of underage girls how
long did prosecutors know about this
incriminating evidence
and later a daring rescue by a by police
of a woman trapped in her sinking
car that was going into a river hear
from the officers who pulled her out to
safety
after this break
[Music]
welcome back a dramatic rescue caught on
camera
captures police saving a woman from her
sinking minivan
angela levy has the video and more
brian this happened in alliance ohio and
from watching this video which is just
under two minutes long you can see that
those officers arrived
just in time
here i got the tomahawk too
sunday night four alliance ohio police
officers raced to the mahoning river
after a woman called 9-1-1 her vehicle
had gone off the road
and into the water oh my god i'm gonna
drown ain't i
they're all there they're gonna get you
out okay please get me out
please get me out here
[Music]
officer christian tussey was in that
cold water trying to help the woman
i got i got you i got you
i need relax hussy relax yeah i will
miss
tell her to get away and bust that
window within 30 seconds
officer tussey pulled her from the van
take this tomahawk
turn away turn away turn away
do it again other side
there all right get out get out
ouch watch mobs there's rocks yeah come
on
is there anyone else in there here is
anyone else in the car
get out here let go moments later
the van sank
and thankfully that woman who was pulled
from the water was treated for just
minor injuries and allowed to go home
police actually think she may have
fallen asleep which caused her
car to go off the road and into the
water now earlier i spoke with the
officers involved in the that rescue two
of them they are officers
christian tussy and shane tillman
so i'm trying to go down as fast as i
could and she goes just jump in
uh that didn't happen uh once i got to
the
the where the water met the land um
i didn't think about it i just entered
the water i i
did think that it was going to be a lot
more shallow than it was though
based on how close i saw the car i i
figured i'd be a knee to thigh deep
water
you know at the time i it is just
another call that's how we look at it we
train for these things and
uh we received recent training as of
this year
to uh a teamwork type issue and that's
if you've seen the videos
that's exactly what we did we had a line
of officers and it's
and to help each other out and not one
of us could have done it alone it took
all of us and
and i thought that was pretty phenomenal
after the fact
and that woman who was rescued actually
thanked the officers for saving her life
as you could see that man was going to
go underwater and did actually go
underwater shortly after she was rescued
those officers remain pretty modest
about what they did that evening
brian i mean thank god for that that
training they're describing
and janet has these officers when you
spoke to them did they tell you that
they've done these rescues before or
just like the first one they've ever
done
yeah you know officer tessie said he had
never experienced a rescue like this in
his nine years on the job but
officer tallman he said he actually had
something similar happened several years
back he said that
there was a rescue that he was involved
in involving a pregnant woman so
that would be very frightening as you
can imagine you'd want to get that woman
out of the water as soon as possible
and they said that they really don't do
this ice water cold water training so
this was really something new for them
angela are there any updates on how the
woman is doing
after this traumatic experience you know
from what we've uh gathered from those
two police officers who i spoke with
they said that she thanked them and um
she's doing okay
obviously it would be very traumatic and
dramatic for this to happen you could
hear just listening to that 9-1-1 call
exactly how
upset and frightened she was she thought
she was going to drown
um and so i think she's very thankful
for what they did
all right ange thank you for that
gripping story
as always great reporting thank you
terry it was quick thinking that saved
the day here what's your take on these
officers heroic efforts
listen when i watched that clip i got
chills it was
really good to see police officers who
are you know being shown in a very
positive light they
are definitely heroes and especially
since as we heard they didn't really
have
that type of experience before so kudos
and congratulations and
you know job well done absolutely agree
with everything there at terry
uh still ahead we've got a close eye on
an ohio jury
as they deliberate in a trial over a
fatal pizza delivery order
plus court documents reveal new evidence
in a case against deceased pedophile
jeffrey epstein and his madam we'll
explain what this means for the criminal
prosecution of elaine maxwell
next
[Music]
and we're back the mysterious doe one in
the gelane maxwell civil case
has been identified as million as
millionaire pedophile jeffrey epstein's
former house manager
a newly unsealed deposition has revealed
maxwell is accused
of taking photos of topless young girls
at epstein's homes maxwell is currently
in isolation
due to a coven 19 outbreak in her jail
she is facing charges of sex trafficking
and perjury former federal prosecutor
and law and crime analyst gene rossi
is questioning when authorities knew
about this testimony
oh it adds rocket fuel this is this is
explosive the southern district of new
york where she's being prosecuted
uh this just is incredibly important
evidence against her
and it just it just amazes me how how
deep and
and pervasive this whole conspiracy was
among epstein miss maxwell and others
to traffic and and take advantage of of
underage girls
and i got to go back to what happened
down in uh miami with the us attorney's
office and acosta
that plea deal that uh they worked out
at the state level
and the u.s attorney's office was asleep
at the switch
it just makes me really upset makes it
really upset
rocker fuel's a good way to describe it
here to discuss this case is criminal
defense attorney linda kenny baden
along with terry austin linda this
testimony
may just be from a deposition but it
definitely can come into a civil case
and potentially a criminal case can you
talk to us about the effects of how this
testimony could affect that criminal
case
well let's first start with any jury
pool out there you know people
don't like anyone whether it's a man a
woman
or anyone is going to take pictures of
young girls and put them in an album
which is what the allegation is here uh
the problem is is
does the southern district have the
albums or is this
relying on the testimony of mr alessi
who was the house manager that's the
first thing the second thing in a
criminal case
remember she's being charged with
perjury okay and then also the sex
trafficking
are any of the young girls that were
taken pictures of number one
you have to establish their age and are
they any of the plaintiffs
uh in the civil suits that we've seen
against the jeffrey epstein estate
so there's a myriad of uses here brian
all in all it doesn't make her look very
good
exactly terry these depositions became
unsealed after
uh public records requests by the miami
herald and doggett investigation
and as linda is saying kind of like i
don't know we make it start a hashtag
hashtag where are the albums
um how long do you think that the
authorities
knew about uh these allegations and
these albums
i don't think the authorities knew about
it for very long because i think they
would
have turned it over to the prosecution
remember they're going to try to go
after maxwell with
every single piece of evidence that they
possibly can have so
i think these pictures are really
damaging and i think
it will absolutely help as far as
charges against her are concerned
and so i don't think that they had the
information for very long
at all and now that they have it they
will probably do everything they can
to use it against her yeah and again
it's going to be interesting this is
just testimony are we going to see
photos are we going to see a whole album
not sure if we're going to continue to
follow the gala in case and when we come
back we're taking you
inside the courtroom as a jury decides
if an ohio woman placed a fake pizza
order
to lure her husband's ex to her death
stay with us
we're back in ohio as a jury is
deliberating in the murder trial of a
woman accused of luring an
army veteran to her death ashley biggs
was strangled and her body was found in
a cornfield
in 2012. chad cobb the father of her
daughter
pled guilty but now authorities are
accusing cobb's then-wife erica stefanco
of playing a role in the murder
prosecutors say stefanko unknowingly
confessed
on a secret recording made by her
mother-in-law but her defense says chad
cobb is the one true killer
he pled guilty to his entire indictment
that indictment only had one name on it
chad cobb he then drives that car
to this area
farmland he hides it there but what's
interesting
is that that property is close to whose
cindy cobb and jacob
why does chad hide it there he knows
that area he knows it
real well
right afterwards he calls
whom who's the first person he calls his
mother
prosecutors responded to the defense's
argument laying out exactly
why they believe erica stefanco is
guilty of murder
there's no forensic evidence because she
was never there during the killing
she had made the call and waited to pick
him up or to follow him
dropped him off and then waited to
follow him and to take him home from
that cornfield
mr o'brien had mentioned the fact that
why didn't cindy cobb
turn this in because she thought it had
no value because she didn't think that
erica was really
you know telling the truth or i guess
didn't believe her
i think the same reason ms cobb didn't
turn it in
and this is the same reason that erica
said the things she said
they didn't understand the law of
complicity they didn't understand that
you don't have to be the one going into
the bank
you don't have to be the one that
actually does the killing
you just have to be the one that helps
the one
who does the killing what does she do
she called dominoes to lure somebody to
their death
that's complicity i mean that's an
interesting reason why the mother didn't
turn over the video
or the audio but let's put that aside
for a second terry
prosecutors say chad cobb killed biggs
chad cobb says
he didn't strangle her if the
prosecutors can't even get their story
right
how does a jury do that well they're
clearly having problems they've already
been deliberating for nine hours i think
the problem here
is you know we know chad cobb is trying
to blame it on stefanko
obviously the prosecution is trying to
blame it on stefanko so
they needed to get their story together
and the prosecution needed to prep maybe
that was the issue he didn't get a
chance to
prep chad cobb but you know frankly the
fact is now
everything is confused and the jury is
going to have a hard time trying to
conclude
who in fact did kill biggs poor
preparation can be this case is undoing
uh linda erica stefanko divorces cobb
after he's arrested then marries his
boss
slash friend and the mom then comes
forward with these recordings later the
defense is kind of
trying to argue that the cobs have an
axe to grind against stefanko
but do you think that's enough to avoid
a conviction here
well you know you hate chad cobb so much
because he's a killer and in the
courtroom he said i'm not the one who
strangled
actually big sir you know so he's trying
to now blame erica stefanko so something
else is going on so the question is
does the jury think the tape is accurate
or will there something else is going on
you know stub one juror and give them a
reason to say
hey we are hung we can't come to a
verdict
hey it's just proof beyond a reasonable
doubt and if you can interject that
reasonable doubt
maybe the axe to grind maybe the the the
the
audio recording isn't enough linda terry
i want to thank you for coming out as
always and thanks to you
for joining us here on the law on crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you